we're lowkeys we survived
fifth episode of loki
journey into mystery so
this is going to be a little bit of an
odd one for me to talk about because i
don't know how much of it i'm going to
spend talking about the episode itself
and i'm going to do something i don't
usually do i'm going to get a bit more
into speculation
i will give a heads up before i do that
because potentially if i'm
right about any of the things that i'm
going to suggest then that's
spoiler territory for the finale and i
don't want to do that to you
without warning but let's talk about
this so
we pick up pretty much right where we
left off which is
the loki we know tom hiddleston dealing
with
well this uh this
cuatro quartet that's the word
of loki's uh including an alligator
and richard e grant being flippin
awesome because he's richard e grant
like okay
richard richard e grant is one of those
actors who
outside of the uk like i wish was better
known he's kind of one of those
oh yeah guys in the us but like he's so
good he's good in everything he was even
good in hudson hawk for crying out loud
so the guy who really deserves more
recognition and
i kind of hope that maybe this buoys him
a little bit more the thing is like he
seems to be very happy
existing in the weird sort of one
appearance
but memorable niche sort of thing that
he's been had for the past few decades
in a lot of series and stuff like that
so
like if he's happy where he is that's
fine but like he's so good
but we pick up there and we get
introduced to this whole idea of
the void and of the i can't remember
what they called it now but the
cloud monster it's the smoke monster
from lost that's what it is
um but this thing that is devouring what
shows up in the void
so the idea of the void is kind of neat
i was
once once we got an explanation of what
it was which is basically just the
dumping ground for not only
variants but anything that gets um reset
out of a timeline i was a little
disappointed that it was
as sort of like just generic
apocalypse especially considering like
how many of the buildings i mean part of
it was it was so overcast and great
maybe there was more interesting designs
going on
but most of the buildings we seen just
look like wrecked earth
you know last hundred years or so style
buildings which
given what the concept of the void is i
would have liked to have seen a much
greater variety but then again like we
don't spend that much time on the
surface so
maybe it would have been a waste of time
and talent to design
something more varied and intricate
you know to sink your money into that
when it ultimately doesn't matter that
much but you know
it's one of those things where the
concept could have given them a reason
to go a little crazier and they didn't
and that's a little bit like now
i i always respect when something gives
itself license to go nuts but then i get
disappointed when it
feels restrained i'm like but okay
but i i do like these four i like that
uh ultimately like this is i said i
wasn't going to get a spoiler so i'm not
going to get into spoilers speculative
but like i'm going to talk about this
episode openly so
it's still good the my main um concern
at this point is the way the entire
thing has been built and it's very clear
now from this point
this is a show that's really going to
hinge on its last episode
which makes me continue to be nervous
like all these episodes have been good
in varying ways but so much of this is
going to hinge on sticking the landing
that i'm going to be nervous going to
the next one
like i just am i can't help it but
that's my general thing this was still
good i enjoyed it
but now i'm going to talk openly about
this and i'll give you the heads up
before i get into any kind of
speculation i like that
um most of these loki's just can't
stop themselves from betraying each
other
like they just can't they just can't do
it
you know we have the the loki with the
with the um
political pin show up and he's like
trying to take over from the others and
one of them betrayed
the other two and then the that loki
with the pins
army he betrays him god he can't help
himself he just keeps
double crossing himself and to me it
actually makes a lot of sense that the
only two well three who don't are
um old loki who we get enough backstory
on
that we really get a sense that he just
lived long enough to not see the point
in that kind of living
and young loki who first of all
good way to turn him into an immediate
badass by having this little kid go i
killed thor
okay but also like he's young enough to
not have developed
all of the bad habits yet that the adult
loki's have
and then of course there's alligator
loki who honestly
i i don't i don't need to know more we
don't really get a lot of insight into
alligator loki
i don't care i don't need it he's great
just by being that's enough for me
it is interesting to me that despite the
other variants we don't even catch a
glimpse
of another female loki which does really
single out sylvia's being
particularly unique in that respect
now i'm not going to delve too much into
that i'm i'm
percolating and depending on the last
episode when i do my overview on this
whole thing
i might focus on the gender aspects of
that and the
implications and thematics and my sort
of read on all that
i haven't decided yet but i am kind of
cataloging all these things to decide
is that what i want to make the focus
when i talk about this thing as a whole
i don't know maybe we'll see
so um all the backstabbing i dig
it was interesting watching sylvie and
ravona so initially i was kind of like
sylvia you are kind of like being
weirdly trusting of her but then making
it very clear
um before it went on too long that like
oh no she actually doesn't like oh
i was afraid she caught stupid disease
somehow like that would have annoyed the
heck out of me
um also it turns out uh moby is still
alive i mean i figured that was going to
be the case
and here's the thing that could have
been very much
i mean like it could have been
undercutting his death and
like arguably if if you say that he's
showing up again
undercuts that moment where he died
previous episode
i can't say that you're wrong for me the
reason it doesn't undercut it is because
he's not just back he's back with a new
purpose and a new mission
and i love the idea that he heads back
to the tva
to in his own words burn it to the
ground i'm like yes
yes give me mobius on a vendetta
i'm here for it so does it undercut his
death
yeah a little but it's not like it's
just like oh he's back and it's fine
it's like no he's back and
different like cool cool that makes it
work
for me so the other thing that's
interesting
is realizing with ravonna even though
she was
stalling to try and you know contain
silvie
and what you still be you know knew
better than to trust her and all that
that there was still some truth that
leaked in
through what ravona was saying in terms
of what the void was
in terms of her confirming that
confirming sylvie's theory that
whatever the real time keeper is or are
is on the other side of the void that
you'd have to travel through it
um like i myself was like oh you have a
void
traveling spaceship boy that's freaking
convenient and i love that sylvie
basically comes the same thing who's
like ah
uh-huh yeah right i believe that so that
really worked as a pivot point for
sylvia to
to start picking apart what ravonna was
doing but
what's really interesting to me is
ravona is not blindly loyal at this
point
she's still holding to the mission she
does still seem to believe in the core
of what the tva is supposed to do
but she clearly now knows she's been
lied to about why
and by who and she's not totally okay
with that
she's not prepared to abandon the entire
mission the way that mobius was when he
realized that
he's a variant and has been kidnapped
out of a timeline and had a life prior
to this
so she's not that far but she is like
okay something's wrong
and i need to know what's really going
on if i'm going to be able to stop these
these loki's and what's going on and so
i like that she's not just
putting on blinders to the entire
situation
that she is still trying to figure out
what's going on just with a different
motivation
and a different intention than loki or
sylvia are
so like that i think is very cool um
like random thing that i forgot to
mention before i like that the loki
seemed to have different specializations
and that richard e grant's old loki is
like
very much into the duplication casting
and the illusions like
that he's so big into that and really
like
i got a smile on my face when he
recreated asgard i'm like oh
why am i so down with this and i like
that the young girl okay big into the
daggers
i i liked those those shifts those
things
we have more leaning on the idea of loki
and sylvie
being romantically into each other i
didn't need more of that i mean they
still haven't
flat out set it which i appreciate i
expect they will by the end
and i just i didn't really need the
whole thing with the blanket and that
extended scene like again
it's not even badly done for what it is
it's pretty well done
and if that's your bag you probably
enjoyed that but i just like
i'm not here for it it's it's not what
i'm here for it's not what i
like about this show these kinds of
stories in general so i find it
i find it grinds things to a halt a
little bit i mean last episode didn't
bother me so much because
they were like big it was either a big
melancholy moment when they thought they
were going to die
so you know them pausing to interact
like made sense what the hell else are
they going to do
or it was this moment in the climax that
didn't last too long
and it was punctuated really well with
loki getting pruned so
i didn't mind it last episode here it
feels a bit more invasive and a bit more
let's put
everything on pause and have this little
cute
semi-romantic scene i'm like
can we move on the idea of sylvia
enchanting
uh the smoke monster from lost uh yes
i'm sticking with that why the hell not
i it's it's interesting um and i like
the idea that um she says you know that
loki can't help her he's like i don't
know how to do this and she's like yes
you do
because i can and that's sort of
reinforced also by the end
by watching richard grant do these
massive illusions that neither of them
think they could do and loki's just like
i think we are capable of more than we
think we are
and that's just kind of a cool thing to
just sort of set up to potentially allow
for further
growth and development of what loki's
even capable of doing on
his her their own so
i think that is uh that was pretty well
done and well handled
i mean the smoke monster as a threat was
it was generic
but it's only around for one episode so
like i'll deal with the generic threat
for one episode but
that brings us to it ends with them
going to presumably figure out who the
hell is behind all this and this is
where i'm gonna get speculative
so if you are worried about hearing any
potential spoilers about where things
are going to go
with the last episode this is your time
to step
away all right all right so
in many ways the obvious choice is still
to have
the reveal be kang the conqueror because
kang
has ties with ravona and the comics and
just as
a time traveling villain this kind of
fits his mo
you know in terms of the sort of
ridiculousness the taking on alter egos
pretending to be other things like this
is all very kang
so it would have been um easy to just go
that way
i'm still kind of holding out hope and
crossing my fingers
that it's not for a couple of reasons
first is
kang as a character he's not great
like that doesn't automatically mean he
won't work in the mcu the mcu has
actually been very good about
streamlining its characters finding new
ways to portray them so
it's absolutely perfectly plausible that
when we eventually see kang
be it here or be it in ant-man 3
that they will have reformed him in a
way that will actually work
so like i'm certainly not discounting
that but he's not a character i'm gonna
get excited about in and of itself
that's problem number one
problem number two if they reveal
kang at the sixth episode of this
that's not going to mean anything to
anybody other than the comic book
readers
and i think that's a bad way for these
things to it was part of the same
problem that i had with wandavision
because they reveal agatha harkness and
unless you
know the comic lore really well you're
just going
who and that potentially
is the same thing and the only way to
have it mean anything is to spend like
15 20 minutes of the last episode
explaining who the hell this guy is
and basically explaining at the last
minute why viewers should care and
that's not
good storytelling especially when they
have
been delaying and hinting at this kind
of reveal for as long as they have like
i
called i think episode one even that the
timekeepers weren't real and there was
something else behind
them so but even if you weren't calling
it early on like i was they've been
hinting at it very directly
and now we have had uh since episode
four
it's been very clear that's definitely
the case so
we're now in a situation where there is
at
minimum half as half uh the show worth
of build
up if not the whole show depending on
how early you had the idea that the
timekeepers weren't real
having that build up to a character that
casual viewers aren't gonna know and
even most comic book fans are gonna be
like oh yeah that guy
not a great plan in my hope that they
don't
do kang i found myself starting to think
well who else
could it be i've got
primarily two options because i was
trying to think
okay who's powerful enough that we have
seen
in the mcu to potentially be behind
all this and i tried to think of like
well ego
maybe but like no none of his stuff is
time related i don't think that works
and a lot of the really powerful
characters have been flat out
killed because most of the most powerful
characters have been
villains because you make the most
powerful things villains so that the
heroes are the underdogs
that's duh so it did leave me a position
where i'm like
now to be fair it could still be
somebody who we saw
die because of possible
variants and time diversions and maybe
whoever's running is like a variant
themselves
um there's the possibility of like
i don't think this for even a second but
if you want to go crazy there's the
possibility of
having it be something like
apocalypse and then have this tie into
the mcu and introduce the idea of
mutants as being from a variant timeline
and
ultimately mesh all of it together i
don't think they'll do that for the same
reason that they didn't do it in one
division
it's too complicated a way to introduce
the entire idea of mutants into the mcu
and also doing it in a show when it's
when it would have to by definition
ripple out and
impact the movies i don't think they're
going to do that
and that's not just like these shows are
proving to be more
impactful in the movies than i
originally thought they were but they
are
still so far being designed to be
skippable and still be able to follow
what's
what's going on in the movies next
captain america movie is just going to
be sam as captain america
and if you didn't watch the falcon in
the winter soldier you'll just see him
as captain america and you'll
logically go okay steve gave him the
shield at the end of end game and now
he's captain america and you can just
make that
leap without having to have seen falcon
in the winter soldier and that's how i
expect these things are going to be
built
so something like something like that
that's going to introduce massive ideas
to set up for the movies i
i still strongly think they will not do
that
so who does that leave in terms of
characters
we already know who in
some way might relate to timer are
powerful enough to have put all of this
together
i've got two options and they're related
first up
how about the ancient one yeah the
ancient one died in the first doctor
strange but
we also brought her back for a little
bit
in end game and introduced to her there
the idea of the
branching timelines and things going
that way did that plant a seed for
something
when she made the case of white so
important that
these these branches not form whole new
dimensions
did that make her think i have to form
something
that keeps all of this in check
or and i think this is out of these two
the more likely possibility i don't
really
i'm not sure i think any either of these
will happen but what if it's doctor
strange
because that would that would work on a
couple of levels
first off if you need to it could be an
alternate timeline doctor strange as
opposed to the one that we know so that
you're not doing character assassination
on the guy
that's the first thing second of all we
know he messes with time we've been
watching him do it since
his first movie the whole thing in
infinity war we saw every single
possibility did he see a whole bunch of
possibilities where he's like these
options shouldn't even exist
and did he take it as a responsibility
to deal with this himself
and more importantly
loki knows doctor strange and they have
met
so him going there and seeing stephen
strange would actually mean something
not just to the audience
but to loki because otherwise we run the
risk of being in a situation
where we have a reveal of someone that
the audience knows but the characters
don't
stephen strange would work really well
he does time shenanigans we've opened up
the possibility of variants
who are handling things differently
enough that it could
be that or it could be setting up
the eventual conflict between him and
wanda
because with what we saw at the very end
of one division and wanda messing around
with the darkhold
and if doctor strange is trying to
control things to this degree
that could very well put them on a
collision course
again in a way that could be picked up
in the eventual movie
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness that
doesn't require you to have watched both
of these because you can just with a
with a line here or two
with a here or two with a line or two
here or there
you can still set up why they're in
conflict in the movie
so that's kind of what i'm hoping for
and this is rare for me i don't usually
do speculation part of the reason is
i hate the idea that i'm going to think
of something that i like better than
what they actually end up doing
i like to think i'm not petty enough to
just go oh they didn't do what i wanted
so now i'm mad but like
if i like my idea better that's a
potential issue
that said that's my prediction we'll see
if i'm right in a week
and if i'm not right i hope they think
of something better
so uh that'll do it for me folks loki
episode five
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down on
the top
i can talk drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it i got a
patreon that's how i pay my bills it's
how i afford disney plus it's how i keep
talking
about these things any support you're
able to give me there
is of great assistance there are
benefits for every tier
early access to videos participation
polls discord etc etc
but even if you're not able to do that
there's youtube memberships as an option
you don't want to do that that's fine
too because at the end of the day
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]